you
the original nintendo entertainment
system or nes just celebrated its
30-year anniversary here in the US now a
lot of people still have their original
nes myself included but odds are they
don't exactly work too well I mean let's
be honest they really never work that
well so sure you can get one of those
cheap emulations knockoffs out there
that water down the experience or you
can opt for something like this this is
the analog NT and it's a built from the
ground up reproduction of the original
nes this uses the same cpu and ppu chips
found in the nes to run games giving you
an exact replication of that system and
the way it played now this is the
ultimate console for nes purists for the
gamer who wants that uncompromised
experience on a modern TV analog really
did their homework here this thing is
gorgeous right down to this circuit
board and the consoles got some real way
to it I mean this is a solid block of
aluminum right here it just feels very
significant it's clear a lot of
attention and respect was put into the
manufacturing of the device now out of
the box the console can play any NES or
Famicom game Famicom is what it was
called in Japan and that totals over a
thousand titles it's got two separate
slots for NES and family con cartridges
as well there's also for NES format
controller ports up front and the system
already ships with two to get you
started so I've been holding off a bit
on the price of the analog NT and that's
because it starts at five hundred
dollars which yes is a lot of money and
if you want the impressive HDMI HD up
converter that's an extra seventy
dollars okay so if you're thinking about
getting one of these you almost have to
get that HD upgrade so you can play
games in 720 or 1080 P but I mean look
at this quality it really is like a
pixel perfect experience there's also a
quick menu that's loaded into the system
that lets you mess around with the
resolution and a few other settings
filters and processing now the NT does a
great job of
playing your old NES games and it could
actually breathe new life into your old
school collection if you've got a bunch
of 8-bit games laying around collecting
dust i know i have a whole trunk full of
them at my parents house now yes at five
hundred dollars the analog NT is
obviously not for everyone but in the
same way that an audio file is looking
for an uncompressed rich sound or the
way a hardcore movie buff wants that
perfect reproduction of a classic film
the analog NT does that for original NES
games if you're willing to pay for it
I'm Jeff Bakalar thanks for watching